in the side meeting I was in the main
message was who will be the spokesperson
who is this trusted messenger who will
drive The Innovation platform and what
was clear was that we may be sidelined
traditional leaders we have not looked
at non scientists non uh technocrats and
we should be focusing more on empowering
them with the scientific evidence
because they live in these basins they
are the ones who are affected by these
problems and they should be given
capacity to inform policy processes
that's where sustainability will come
from African institutions are weak they
are weak because we have not invested in
research there's still very little
appreciation of the role that research
plays in development and for as long as
our researchers are sitting idle with no
resources they doing their research in a
closet within the station and not
getting out to the farmers there is no
way that we are going to help Africa
feed itself so I think the starting
point is a call on governance can we use
African money to invest in African
research institutions that way we will
have researchers who can follow the
development agenda we have policies that
cannot be implemented because they are
created bottom down we want policies
that are created bottom up where the
evidence comes from practitioners but
it's packaged such that it can fed
directly into policy and I think that's
what the Innovation platforms have a new
way of doing business where you don't
stop a project level but you move
vertically to inform change at a higher
level District National and Regional
level so that you have policies that
save the
people really it's exciting because
Innovation platform is about equipping
all the actors to be drivers of change
but we are saying this change has to be
led through evidence and evidence that
emanates from research so when we are
talking about impact and outcomes the
the chain starts from those who are
affected by the problem being around the
table and those who want to experiment
research and deliver options for
development sitting as equal partners
and that's what the new CG
is